like you still
got feelings for him
yeah
that's honest
i appreciate that yeah
what makes you stay you just feel like
you can't walk away
um
or do you do you think at some point
he'll change his mind
i think i did think that mm-hmm
i definitely think i was maybe living in
a bit of hope
maybe there's like a bit of a charac
being dangled in front of me
you know when i was realizing or when i
was questioning certain things
um
i think i'm probably in a better place
now because i'm quite aware of what the
situation is
and i'm quite ready to just kind of you
know like move forward
which is great
um
i can't knock him completely because i
feel like there was a lot of things he
showed me you know how we're talking
about actions speak louder than words
um
and i think some women will
ignore that
because it's not what they want to see
it's not what they want to feel
you know they want to believe like nah
this guy's right for them
um but in reality if someone is showing
you something yeah you've really got to
take that in
so um how old did you say you are 33 33
do you ever worry like do you want a
family and like kids and stuff i've got
a son okay he's 14. okay um
i would want to have
another child however i do feel like i'm
on a
short time frame now yeah well because i
would just think um
because i i've like broken up with
people or like ended things because
i don't want to waste time and because
you only have so much youth you know do
you ever worry you can't find someone
else because you're still emotionally
invested in this guy
absolutely
yeah i feel like i've probably done that
for quite a while yeah
so i definitely think that um
i call it blocking my blessings
you know
if you're emotionally invested in
someone else
then you might miss
someone amazing because
you're mentally still there do you know
what i mean
um
yeah i think it's just i think women
generally speaking i think there's a lot
of us that do need to
really take in
what's put in front of us
so and this is a common like complaint i
hear from guys because like they value
you know purity and they value youth
right and so like a common complaint is
okay you passed over me in your 20s in
your early 30s
and now you're expecting me to come in
at 35 and deal with all the damage that
the previous guys have done for the past
decade
and it's it's funny because everyone's
like nodding they're like yeah that
happens
it's a shame then do you so do you feel
like that's for men an unfair deal
yes yeah i do wow that's bigger you to
say it's not fair because i don't
believe they should have to deal with
anyone's past trauma yeah that's been
caused by someone else
i think it's amazing if you do meet a
man that wants to be understanding to
that level where they want to try and
fix that or help you to heal
but i definitely don't think it's fair
that women
put their past trauma onto someone new
that they meet someone that comes into
their life that hasn't done nothing to
them they might that man might be
amazing it might be great you know but
because we've experienced
bad experiences and we've got that
trauma and that bit of scarring
we project that onto them
that's because you haven't healed yeah
you haven't taken that self that time
for yourself to focus and heal and deal
with over whatever your problems were or
your insecurities and then you just hand
it on to the next person and obviously
nobody's going to handle that well so so
what is healing to you because i always
hear this and i don't i don't think you
can
like you
they say the average person falls in
love three times in their lifetime
so you only get so many chances at love
and it's like i don't think anyone fully
heals
no i think when i when i refer to the
term as healing i'm i'm like take
yourself back
look at the situation look at the
mistakes you may have made yourself
look at the things you allowed to happen
that might have hurt you
and and vice versa what the things that
you may have done to that partner in
order for them to behave in a certain
way that you've then felt again was
targeted so i think when i say healing
i'm take yourself back
take some time out you know just focus
on your health focus on your mental
well-being
and do whatever it takes whether it's
meditation whether it's a holiday
whether it's reading books like learning
a new skill
that to me is healing so when i've
healed myself in the past i haven't
gone to
a therapist on a telephone that i don't
know and i'm not saying that that's not
the right thing to do or that it's the
wrong thing to do but for me i just took
time out i stopped dating
i separated anyone from my life that
maybe i felt was putting me in a
predicament or making me behave or act a
certain way and just focused on me
and then eventually you come back to
yourself and
so
again a common complaint that i hear
from guys that it's funny because as a
girl like i know exactly what you're
saying but a lot of times when guys hear
this that sounds like nonsense yeah
and it's because there's no tangible
result
like there's nothing that you can
measure and say that you did it's just
like okay you went on a vacation
i don't know and you thought about what
you did wrong and you're gonna do it
better like how do they know you're
gonna do it better in the future
yeah
i'm thinking about the other one like
what what have you achieved after that
yeah like when i say a vacation i'm
talking six months somewhere
i'm not talking a holiday to ibiza for
seven days with the girls and hey i'm
over you yeah like i'm talking like
somewhere where you really really take
yourself out of your current lifestyle
your daily routine and then you can
evaluate and obviously there is no time
on healing healing probably takes years
it's not like you never get over
everything
but healing to a point then you don't
transfer it onto the next relationship
but i don't think you can not transfer
things to another you can
if you take enough time i feel like you
can you can but there's always going to
be things that may trigger you and it's
up to you
i don't i i genuinely think that there's
some things that your partner might do
that will
prompt a random response
basically yeah like you didn't even know
that you had and that's the moment you
take a step back and you're like okay i
haven't dealt with this i'm going to
revisit that but also take the time and
be courteous enough to inform your
partner like hey listen if you guys
haven't had that conversation
this is what i dealt with please bear
with me
it will not happen again if you see it
does let me know feel comfortable to let
me know
so i really think that healing is
something that can take place also in a
relationship but you have had to have
done the bulk of the work for yourself
do you think that healing needs to have
therapy so there's some tangible result
because it's like if you're just talking
to your friends like they're more likely
to tell you what you want to hear
where where a therapist will like sit
you down and tell you about yourself
therapy and i'm currently doing therapy
right now and at first i was just like
this is like what white people do like
no literally because no no no literally
this is this is literally my thought
process and even all the people around
me when i finally told them i'm gonna do
therapy they're like were you doing
fairy people that's like white people
stuff it completely changed my life like
completely the first thing i realized
was there's a lot of